lobstermen and women in maine brought in
a record catch of last year about 80% of
lobsters caught in the u.s. come from
the state the record is good news for
the growing ranks of lobster roll lovers
around the world me included but prices
for the glorified lobster sandwich have
been on the rise hovering around 20
dollars Don Dahler is in Tenants Harbor
Maine with a lesson in lobster economics
Don good morning good morning over the
past few hours six lobster boats pulled
away from here heading out on their
daily task of pulling up hundreds of
these lobster traps in search of that
tasty treasure of the sea but it wasn't
always viewed as such lobster was once
so disdained as food it was fed only to
prisoners no longer now when it comes to
coveted seafood lobster is king if there
was an official food of summer the
lobster roll would be a lead contender
it's the essence of summer and always
makes me feel like I'm at the beach
and it's not just in New England you can
now get an authentic Maine lobster roll
pretty much anywhere around the u.s. Oh
any way you can have lobster I like to
have lobster you can also find the
seafood treat at McDonald's in six
northeastern states I think it's a
hamburger of the sea just a big lobster
fan so like anything is good this we
have your box ready as demand for this
delicacy has gone up so has its price
two years ago or even last year was
cheap and it's kind of like oh wow
lobster was in everything and now it's
kind of think back to being a little bit
more of a luxury many people think of
Maine they think of lobster they come
here they want a lobster so it's
important that we captured that feeling
Matt Jacobson leads an organization
touting Maine lobster around the world
it's there that affordable luxury right
for the vacation on a plate the journey
to that plate begins here in the waters
off Maine that have the perfect
temperature to nurture lobsters Tom
Martin is one of almost 6,000 licensed
lobstermen who are benefiting from an
underwater population explosion last
year Maine lobster men pulled up a
record 130 million pounds that's nearly
double what they were bringing in ten
years ago the catch keeps going up and
the demand keeps going up a little bit
faster so the prices stay up which is
good for ya awfully obviously really
good for the fishermen we haven't really
seen a very strong catch yet this season
but that could change any day now
we got to find more markets for all the
fish right I mean we've got a lot of
life so we got to find more mouths to
eat it and they have looking forward to
this as demand has exploded worldwide
especially Asia so of prices when we
started Luke's back in 2009 we were
buying lobster meat for $14 a pound now
we're now up to $30 a pound for lobster
meat Luke Holden is a third-generation
lobstermen he's also the entrepreneur
behind Luke's lobsters
he and his partner started with one
Lobster Shack in New York they now have
more than 25 in the United States and
six in Japan if the supply so good why
are the prices still so high the demand
has continued to grow at that
exponential rate so now we've got a
market where demand I think is in excess
of supply so we've got a very stable
price Luke's lobsters processing arm
cape seafood expects to ship five
million pounds this year part of a
crucial industry for Maine these
crustaceans contribute more than 1
billion dollars a year to the state's
economy and contribute to a way of life
that goes back generations and a new
culinary experience for many gaining a
lot of fans I was expensive but it's
worth it once a month you got a splurge
every now and then this season has
started off a little more slowly than
past years but we're told that should
pick up over the next few days now
unlike other fisheries around the world
Maine's lobster beds are thriving in
part because fishermen long ago set
strict limits to the size of the
lobsters they could keep they want them
to be three and a quarter inches the
back part of the lobster here they have
to be bigger than that but they don't
want them too big and they want
absolutely no reproducing females Nora
oh there you go done thank you how do
you like your Lobster
I like to drive up to the coast of Maine
there to Georgetown a new Harbor and you
know with the family and you just those
are the best place to go to the lobster
shacks not you know it's one thing in a
restaurant it's another actually getting
it in Maine instead the season slow
after that segment I think it's gonna
shake up quickly thank you so we're all
hungry